[Music]
this summer a lot of Epic anime were
released such as Jiu Jitsu Kaizen Season
2 mushoku tensei Season 2 bleach and
many more all with amazing storylines
and spectacular animations but in this
video we'll be showcasing some of the
best fights in the summer anime lists so
far prepared to be amazed as we dive
into the epic showdown between
characters in their respective verses
[Music]
if you're a fan of classic anime then
you'll surely recognize this one we have
ruroni Kenshin himura versus ginay we
all know who Kenshin himura is but G
Nate might be someone who you don't
remember at all he's an assassin and the
fight between him and Kenshin is a great
opening for this video at this moment
Ken Shin uses Bato Jutsu and we all knew
jinay was done for the speed at which
Kenshin pulled out his Blade the slow
motion movement as the blade was about
to reach Gina and the way Gina reacted
were absolutely satisfying to watch Gina
even thought he would win but just like
that Kenshin pulled out a double but
though Jutsu using the sheath of his
sword sealing the deal the Remake did an
amazing job of making the animation fit
the modern era while still retaining
that classic feel even before that
batojutsu attack if Kenshin didn't have
a reverse blade sword then G Nate would
have been defeated right on the spot
this fight just showed just how far the
difference between Kenshin and DNA
skills are
moving on we have Buddha versus harjun
in record of Ragnarok
initially Buddha was supposed to fight
zero fuku the God of Misfortune he's
also the fusion of the seven lucky Gods
being their original form before
splitting up in the past in a twisted
turn of events zero Fuko becomes a
vessel for the demon king of the sixth
heaven harjun and disappears completely
while Buddha was pushed into a corner a
silver lining appeared for him and gave
him a Fighting Chance Buddha was able to
achieve enlightenment along with
xerofuku's soul he was able to use
volender to create his Ultimate Weapon
great Nirvana sword zero and unleashes a
downward slash with tremendous Force
this attack was capable of cutting
harjun's body into pieces the depth of
the story is animation and its
choreography create an effect of
satisfaction and awe for all the viewers
making it one of the best fights not
just in record of Ragnarok but in the
entire 2023 summer anime list
hey you yeah you if you watch this video
then I bet you're a true anime fan so I
have a present for you I give you the
sponsors of this video
Eternal Evolution the Eternal evolution
is an idol strategic RPG that you can
play on your own smartphone which means
you can play it whether you're on the
plane on a train or even when you're
lining up for the next Anime Con it's
free to play friendly and you can
download it on both Android iOS and even
PC simulator which is really rare to
find from AFK PVE PVP and you even have
Guild but it doesn't end there because
they're collaborating with a legendary
anime franchise that you might just know
it's Ghost in the Shell Sac 2045
Eternal Evolution will be introducing
four brand new Heroes a new world boss
story challenge lots of rewards and even
a new gacha exclusively for this
collaboration and if you're a new player
go and participate in the grand ceremony
event and you'll get a SSS hero Ravenna
for free but what I truly love is their
new Heroes look at motoko kusanagi she's
the main character of Ghost in the Shell
Sac 2045 and I personally adore how they
designed her in this collaboration so
fraternal evolution is right up your
alley click on my link in the
description below or scan the QR code
right here so you can download Eternal
Evolution and join the collaboration
event right now use the promo code e e
Sac 2045 an experienced Ghost in the
Shell Sac 2045 back to the video
damn
moving on we have one of the craziest
fight scenes in any anime this summer
2023 Akira versus the walking shark
zombie in zom 100 what made this utterly
ridiculous was that nobody expected a
shark to grow legs after it turned into
a zombie well it didn't exactly grow
legs but aside from that it's still
worthy of this list Akira's entrance the
camera angles while he was fighting the
monster all the way to his crackle
Thunder Punch it looked like this wasn't
a zombie anime but it was like a scene
straight out of my hero Academia it's
rare to see this kind of Animation
quality much less eye-catching impact
frames in this genre which was the
reason Zone 100 took the anime World by
storm we might have expected to see the
shark explode but it ended even better
seeing as how funny it was to see a
bunch of zombie legs moving around after
the shark turned upside down overall the
zombie shark Punch May probably be a
fight you didn't even think about
encountering in his top 10 but it's up
there for a reason
next up is one of the most anticipated
fights this summer yujiro hanama versus
barking
national gym leader
[Music]
finally the moment every Barky fan has
ever dreamed of the ultimate battle
between Father and Son to decide who's
the strongest has finally happened after
years of training and practice Baki
hanmar feels ready to challenge his
father to the fight that will keep the
entire verse on edge countless matches
countless fights countless injuries and
countless powerful enemies prepared
yujiro hanma's son for this ultimate
moment since what began in the first
series continued three further series
The Baki hanma conclusion is one that's
worth anticipating barky's goal of
competing against his father to become
the strongest man alive served as the
driving force behind all of his efforts
and ultimately came true as he attained
the Pinnacle of his performance Barky
has significantly improved in terms of
speed reflexes technique and Agility
during the past two episodes Sparky
loses the fight figuratively meeting the
same demise as his mother but the young
fighter pulls through and lives to fight
another day the series doesn't come to a
close with a fight it focuses a lot on
the father-son bond but it aims to
strengthen and repair given yujiro's
attitude it's difficult to persuade him
to recognize Barky for his fortitude
endurance adaptability and most
importantly his kid who steals the show
by symbolically cooking for Barky and
resigning the title yujiro finally
acknowledges his son he now announces to
the world that Barky is the new
strongest creature walking the Earth
while in turn Barky confirms that his
father was the winner of the fight
[Music]
next on the list is Captain zanaki
genpachi versus the Visionary Grammy
with the power to make everything you
imagine become reality you think you're
the strongest there is I mean to be
completely honest that's an insanely
strong ability overpowered even you
could just imagine your opponent to
cease existing in the fight's over but
that ability won't defeat kembachi
easily that guy is just him and no one
can take that away being a monster that
defies anything and everything he
demonstrates just why he's the strongest
in the entirety of Soul Society through
sheer strength alone Ken panchi over and
over again stopped and talented whatever
Grammy imagined obliterating a meteor
with a single strike withstanding a
barrage of bullets and missiles and
finally cutting Remy despite being stuck
in space since the battle began Grammy
never stood a speck of a chance against
Zaraki with the captain's display of
overwhelming power Grammy was left with
no choice but to imagine himself
becoming stronger than Zaraki instead of
defeating zanaki he defeated himself in
the process as Grammy managed to imagine
himself being the strongest Kenpachi he
didn't realize that his body couldn't
handle it ultimately leading to his
defeat the last image he saw is he was
falling to his death with Zaraki looking
down on him the animation and conclusion
of the story was so satisfying we just
had to add this one to the list
up next we have the entire fight between
the sorcerer killer and the strongest
sorcerer in Jiu Jitsu Kaizen history
this fight had two rounds and ended with
a 1-1 score but we all know how things
turned out for real during their first
fight toji overwhelmed Gojo in both
speed and smarts to the point where Gojo
got absolutely decimated now that
shocked fans especially Gojo simps out
there seeing as in season 1 Gojo was
portrayed as Untouchable and he even
said that he could win against sukuna
but who knew there was someone that was
able to not only injure him but stab him
in every vital Point known to man oh God
in round two that's when Gojo made one
of the best comebacks in all of anime he
basically resurrected himself using the
reverse curse technique and went on to
become a maniac this round was just as
hype as the first time they faced off
but Gojo Unleashed a secret technique
that blew a hole through toji and Beyond
the animation was Godly and even though
there were some differences from the
manga the studio managed to capture the
impact and emotions that made the fight
very memorable
there you go
now we're in with one of the Heavy
Hitters with fate strange fake Whispers
of dawn Gilgamesh versus enkidu no doubt
this scene by fight is the best animated
one amongst everything on this list I
couldn't stop watching it over and over
again the animation was a true
Masterpiece I was still in awe of
watching it for the tenth time while
making this list the visual effects were
on another level but the story is
something you shouldn't Overlook just
because the animation was superb
Gilgamesh and enkidu are revered as
monsters in their verse and in terms of
combat strength enkidu is equal to
Gilgamesh even though they have the
power to transform all creations
Gilgamesh and kidu share a bond of
friendship and what better way to greet
each other in their reunion than to go
all out ultimately the encounter ended
in a draw since enkid who fell to curse
of death in kudu's natural enemy before
Gilgamesh left he gave his best friend
one final attack that lit up a part of
the world visible from outer space the
depth animation and visual effects of
this scene will certainly put other
anime to shame and that's why this is
one of the best fights in the 2023
summer anime list
foreign
from one well-animated fight scene to
another we have fog Hill of five
elements yishwan and jinshuan versus
shanchu in this fight Chuan and Jing
face off against shanchu who just
achieved his final form making him
stronger than he was before in this two
vs one battle chanchu was trading blows
against the duo and eventually dominated
them proving that in this form his
strength couldn't be matched by anyone
caught in a Thai spot Jing Shuan was in
a lot of trouble as shantu was about to
finish him off with a devastating move
but luckily yishwan stepped in and
tanked the upcoming attack enraged by
this yishwan transformed into a being
that far surpasses shanju's imagination
from here on out the animation looked
like a Chinese classic painting the
animation before yishwan's rage mode was
already a masterpiece but this takes the
cake by far the choreography and visual
effects of the scene will give you
goosebumps every time you remember it in
your mind fog Hill of five elements has
always been renowned for its great
animation this one takes it a step
further
Northwest
[Applause]
[Music]
last but not least we have an entry from
one of the most underrated animes of all
time Blades of the Guardian team Dalma
versus Team hee Schwan Dalma was
outmanned and surrounded by hii Schwan
and his Killers but their advantage
didn't last long because dalmar's
companions arrived and took them by
surprise in both spring and summer 2023
blade of the Guardians has given us some
of the best fight scenes in anime and
this one is no exception it might take
you some time to get used to Chinese
voice acting but once you do it's
definitely worth the watch the animation
in this scene was superb and each of the
characters entrances was just awesome to
look at ayuya's line was Stone Cold
right after she put an arrow through one
of them thalma even used one of heu
Schwan's allies as a human shield it was
brutal cinematic Dynamic and showed just
how strong Dalma and his companions
really are it'll exceed your
expectations and get you hooked on the
series
oh
no
we all knew this was coming we have gear
5 Luffy versus kaido up next Luffy
versus kaido was probably one of the
best fights we've had in one piece and
the emphasis on fights there because it
took Luffy's three whole tries just to
defeat kaido and this last one took the
entire Anime World by storm not only did
we get to see the Pinnacle of Luffy's
strength which is his devil fruit
Awakening but we also saw how
overpowered cartoon characters really
are gear 5 basically turns anything
Luffy touches into a Looney Tune scene
and Luffy himself is impossible however
even with his power up kaido is proving
to be stronger than anyone thought from
Luffy using him as a jumping rope to
Luffy grabbing literal lightning bolts
and throwing them at him and him finally
using his gigantic attack bargeron gun
the straw hat Captain made it one of the
most unique boss fights in anime history
we didn't get to see it finished in one
move but that's why it was amazing to
watch we got to see kaido truly live up
to his name as the strongest creature
while at the same time Luffy became a
literal God their fight spanned entire
episodes and we aren't complaining one
bit everything was perfect from the
different animations the sound effects
and up to the moment where bajirangan
finished kaido off this fight cemented
itself as a legendary moment in anime
foreign
that's about it so far these are my top
10 best fights in the 2023 summer anime
list don't forget to check out our
sponsors game Eternal Evolution links in
the description or just scan the QR code
from your phone smash that like button
share the video and subscribe to my
YouTube channel for more videos like
this one